ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
first
wild ride of 2021 with an incredibly
talented comedian slash musician
you know him as the band leader for
james corden's late late show oh man
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
reggie watts yeah dude
i i'd like you to meet my co-host scott
randolph
how's it going and if you're in gallery
view no mr randall
we've got paul briskey as well what's up
reggie how are you
oh my gosh i see him he's so good
he's looking good it looks like he's in
a motorhome looks like you're in like
you're you're all in separate um motor
homes that's really cool that you're all
in different ones
we bought three just spread out right
okay
so gotta say that that this uh
this podcast got us with you
having you as a guest got us inspired
to start hitting samples right i mean
oh
oh wait that wasn't even the right one
there we go gosh darn it
but oh there we go but i do believe
you're learning even though
we're off to a rocky start i think we're
going to be on a magical journey
oh yeah
on top of the samples how dope does the
picture quality look with the dslr
camera plugged in as the zoom video
oh it's it's diesler it's dieseler
heaven
yeah dude are those dslrs dude those
dsls
yeah but it's g
you like those dsls dude yeah oh man
mdsl especially with the r edition
when they introduced the r it was like
you got
[Music]
thank you for doing this man it's it's
an honor and uh
you know i gotta ask when you uh
introduce yourself or someone's gonna
give you a a title
like are we going with comedian first
what's left i could say like uh
improviser or say comedic improviser
comedic improviser that's probably good
comedic improviser we're not even gonna
include music in the title yeah well you
know it's like
comedic could still be music i don't
know i've been trying to work on it but
you know musician comedic improviser i
don't know if you want to do that that's
fine too
are you are you trying to get away from
the music are you feeling type cast
[ __ ] music no no
no [ __ ] the music no i uh i love music
no i i
i'm always going to be you know music's
always kind of like the first
but i don't know i've been trying to
come up with you know in general i call
myself an
improviser just in general because like
whatever it is technology you know that
kind of stuff so
that's what i've been working on so
trying to figure out how to explain
yourself in like you know
three words or less it's what was the
original pursuit was it
music or was it comedy and then one kind
of
fed into the other yeah now let me just
say that that's a
that's a creepy question because he
knows the answer he's been stalking you
like a [ __ ]
yeah we gotta get a regular walter
conquered him
born in germany
the original pursue was the dsls
okay let me rephrase the question then i
know you originally pursued music you
went to college for music
when did comedy sort of like
because now you're kind of you're known
for comedy and like that
you know so anyway when did those worlds
meld for you so when you were a child
was music well music was just around me
and i had so much i was so in love with
disney no
i uh no i mean it's weird it's a weird
question because
you know i get it once in a while and
every time i think about it i'm like
was it music but i kind of think of it
as i mean formally i studied music
formally first you know piano
specifically
jazz right and well the well i started i
studied classical piano at age five
until 16 and then i also played violin
in school system
for eight years as well and uh was in
choir and had a
had a a band in high school so i i've
done music all my life
but i always was a class clown i love
comedy i did
you know put on my own play in
elementary school
and did like you know debate which is
kind of there's some comedic elements to
it and then
and then high school i did competitive
drama and did stand-up comedy so
in a way i've kind of done both uh all
my life
nice man and you've got accents pretty
dialed huh like
i saw you on conan o'brien and you're a
british guy i'm like oh yeah but then
he's not a british guy
how many accents can you really [ __ ]
do
well you know i i don't really know
because i just kind of
i kind of just feel it but you know but
for sure like you know english
i'd say like okay but please answer the
rest of your question as a branch
when i'm talking like this you know it's
like um it's a very similar
type of way of speaking in the way that
i've heard programs
growing up or whatever and then
sometimes i change my voice like this
and this always kind of corrects
different kind of uh
patina to the audio that you're hearing
into your
your ears right now well sounds pretty
high class
you know it's it's just like that dirty
cockney [ __ ]
yeah it's like you know when you're
talking like this and everyone's staring
at
you and it always sees about your mates
just walking around you know just having
a fight
you know it's like even if that's like
that's about 80 there but
sometimes like it's more like tuning a
radio dial for me you know like
i'll i'll hit it and then suddenly i'm
like oh that's it that's it you know
like leave it there don't touch the dial
like i can like
ride that accent for a while paul i
don't know where the [ __ ] you were on
the applause on that one but for god's
sakes the crowd goes wild
yeah i was scared on that man uh you're
a regular old
[ __ ] swiss army knife when it comes
to this [ __ ] dude like
what uh did you get any cartoon voice
over work in your resume
and my resume yeah uh i uh
i don't know why they call to resume can
i see your resume
no um uh yeah i mean i've done a bunch
of voices i'm in the news uh
square face sponge person uh movie
um and uh i'm also in
uh what is it called uh oh uh puss in
boots two
i play uh the uh the insecurity of
uh puss and then uh yeah i've
been uh there's a cartoon called
wildlife that i'm in
uh there's another one that is about to
come out
yeah there's i don't know this year has
actually been a lot of voice over stuff
so i've done probably like
i don't know six animated things this
year that's great but i love it
congratulations yeah
and now i wonder too when you say this
year
2020 of course is a cartoon voice over a
more
like coveted friendly art
i mean i guess like has that been in
production the whole time
yeah man um yeah
yeah i mean it was it's kind of you know
some of these things i was doing before
uh kovit happened but uh in fact a
couple of them
i i had like one session like in an
actual studio with like the writers and
the producers and stuff like that and
then coveted it and so then it turned
into just
pure uh skype town or zoom or whatever
the hell
and so yeah so you know yes and no it
definitely got amplified because people
were looking for
you know people that were flexible that
you know could
could do things on the fly really easily
and i was just kind of a person that's
i always loved tech anyway so i was
already wired for that stuff even before
the pandemic can't hit so
yeah it was a no-brainer yeah i think
that you should take
improv out of your title and just be
like i'm on um
on the fly comedy on the fly on the fly
i'm on the
[Laughter]
that's the name of my podcast man otf
yeah
i love it do you have a podcast you know
i'm so allergic to
how many of my friends have podcasts at
this point it's just like my you know
cats have podcasts
you know i i think i think i'll get
there i'll get there i have my own
app called whatsapp yeah brilliant yeah
and uh and it's got live streaming
capability and i got my my the guy who
created the app is making me
a friendlier interface so basically i
have my own app
on my phone to to be able to post stuff
to my app
um because uh right now it's like really
convoluted you have to go to a mobile
website and then they have to click all
these things it's really it sucks
so uh
did we just plug our own app and then
[ __ ] all over it
yo yeah definitely definitely please
that's what this show is about right no
it's not at all
where's the where's the app at now you
said before it was it was
a web thing and now you've got it all
tightened up
and it's in good shape and how do people
get it yeah uh
it's um it's on ios and android
you just look for uh whatsapp by reggie
watts or i think even if you type in
reggie watts
because i guess it takes a while for it
to like show up like if you just put
wats app
for it to show up uh because it needs
like time and people searching for it
but
in in the meantime yeah just look for
reggie watts whatsapp it's my last name
and app and uh yeah it'll pop up it's on
android
ios and i'm uploading stuff i sell all
my old
electronics like because i'm constantly
buying new technology so i need to get
rid of it so yeah
so i'm always like giving away like i
mean basically giving away technology
like
this is like half price for a brand new
set of like bose 700s or whatever
but uh it's like yeah so it's kind of
what it what is it
it's like an audio video d-pop shop yeah
it's like a
it's a good back pages yeah you sure
yeah
yeah i'm trying to say i think i can
show you real quick do people
have to subscribe did you just swipe up
with your nose
there you go oh here it is that works
boom
yeah so this is it there's you guys too
yeah hey all right yeah dude
yeah so then you know if you go to the
shop i don't know if i'll be able to
press it
you are good at technology i mean this
guy's the [ __ ]
man marching band dude yeah so so so i
i do all this [ __ ] yeah so it's it's
cool it's like a really basic
app and it rocks man it's it's
you know i'm gonna have live streaming
and i can like do geolocation
[ __ ] um meaning i can if like if i came
up with a single or something i wanted
to release it but you had to stand by
a specific tree in order to listen to it
i can do that so you have to travel
somewhere to hear media so that's pretty
rad so yeah i've been
uh it's it's been fun but i can do live
streaming and so that
to answer your question about podcasts i
think it'll just be my app
you know and then i it won't necessarily
be a podcast it'll just be
part of my app i love it and i was for
the
longest time exactly in your boat i was
just like okay everybody and their mom
has a podcast i can't do
it and then it just seemed to always be
there as
as something that i was neglecting you
know that i really needed to come around
to and
and you know i'm glad i did now good to
meet good to meet
cool people like you yeah man i mean i
always have a way i have a blast i love
doing podcasts
like like you know all my you know when
my friends have podcasts
it's just a blast you know because
you're just getting a chill and hang out
and it's
it's fun you know people love hearing
especially nowadays they just like
hearing a conversation so
you know now's the time anyway so you
know i mean it's crazy people seem to
have
either no [ __ ] attention span at all
like you got to get to them in the first
like
[ __ ] five seconds and then they click
away
or their attention span is just endless
they're like [ __ ] man three hours wasn't
enough
yeah exactly yeah i know isn't that
weird
like i i posted something recently where
i like i got really stoned one night on
an edible and
just started walking around my house
just at first it was like a
demonstration of a new uh
coved hood that i got you know this
thing called biovisor
which is just ridiculous and it's got
all these motors and stuff and
i was like showing that off and then i
showed my other collection of masks that
i've been you know collecting or
whatever
and then it just devolved this whole
thing about like why i like this and why
i like that and check this out and blah
blah for like an
hour and yeah it was like an hour and 40
minutes or something like that
and i can't believe how many people i
put up on my stories for a while and i
can't believe how many people watched it
it was just like i was like that's such
a long period of time
right but i guess people are into it you
know yeah what city are you in right now
are you are you in new york
i gotta say i was actually surprised by
reggie's location
and i think you're gonna be surprised by
mine because i happen to be in a place
called
going hard so hard like a super athlete
that i'm actually training for a bicycle
ride from los
angeles all the way to san diego and
that is
quite a bit over 100 miles and when
you're an athlete at my level
you got to watch out for a common
problem among athletes
which is over hydrating yeah completely
true
that a lot of athletes drink so much
water that it
reduces their electrolytes and sodium to
dangerously low levels
and not only do i have the solution for
you it happens to be the most
generous deal any sponsor has ever
offered the wild ride listeners
it comes from a company called element
it's my favorite
new fitness assistance sponsor
okay they make these packets which you
mix with water and they keep your
electrolytes and your sodium
at perfectly good levels for athletes
like me
okay and they are generously offering
you a completely
free sample pack all you have to pay is
for the shipping and that's only five
bucks so what do you get in this
completely free sample pack you get
eight free packets two of them are
orange
two of them are citrus two of them are
raspberry
and two of them are raw unflavored okay
so to get this completely generous
totally
free sample pack you go to drink
element dot com forward slash stevo
that is d-r-i-n-k-l-m-n-t
dot com slash stevo and remember
this is not available on their regular
website it's
only for the special listeners of the
wild ride podcast
so use that forward slash stevo okay
and the offer is only good for the wild
ride listeners
in the month of january 2021 i love
element
i think you're going to love them too so
get on over to drinkelement.como
for this awesome deal and do it now
okay support the podcast but first find
out where reggie is
i'm in great falls montana holy [ __ ] my
buddy ryan simon eddie's from there
nice oh my god i know simon eddie tim
green
yeah yeah all those cats in fact uh
do you know kojak uh do you know dem
oh damn no i don't know yeah i don't
know he's probably in jail
oh
yeah i've met i've met him he's uh ryan
was uh
he was friends with all my skater crew
yeah
you know i grew up in the 80s and in
great falls and so
a lot of a lot of my friends were
skaters and
uh yeah and so uh yeah
the green like tim green uh and uh
his family and then i don't know if you
know you probably don't know jj thomas
but jj thomas was like he's like he
never really
liked rode pro or anything like that but
he was like really connected with the
montana skate scene
and simon eddie came into town and him
and then tim green
created the skate park here and um or
helped create the skate park here in
great falls so
yeah so i know a lot of a lot of those
guys um and even um
uh tony hawk knew uh simon eddy and tim
green
which was just crazy to me i was like a
skater scene is so
small man it's great simon eddie and i
did
like brian simon eddie and i met in 1996
and i was like kind of a skater wasn't
that great at it but i was like i'll set
myself
on fire and jump off roofs and drink
bong water and ryan was like
really [ __ ] talented at skateboarding
so
everything that i wished i could do he
could do
and i kept coming up with all these
ideas like oh okay well
you'll skate through a fireball while
you're going down a handrail and like
it was just so rad like yeah and then we
ended up
on lollapalooza tour we had this rock
and roll tour bus and
i rented a second tour bus so they were
like
driving in a caravan one and the back
ones towing a u-haul trailer and so
simonetti on moving tour buses boom
ollie from bus to bus boom down to the
u-haul to like
just so so rad by every little [ __ ]
dumb creative idea i would come up with
like he was just capable of pulling we
had more
fun than ever dude just one of my best
friends for life dude
oh man that's so rad yeah i that
that that whole crew at least for me
like the most time i hung out was
you know sometimes i come back to great
falls and i'd run into people but in the
80s like
especially when skateboarding was just
starting to come into the mainstream you
know
like you know it's like everyone was
reading trans world and [ __ ] and it was
like
and having their like little
fingerboards yeah like
it was like that whole cultural thing
like i'm so glad i got to be there
at that time at that age and then see
how
those guys branched out you know and and
started kicking ass
uh that's pretty cool man dude man so do
you live in great falls now or are you
just visiting
no i uh i well i visit my mom
once a month uh she's she lives out here
by herself
but in the house i grew up in so um
so i come out and say yo and i still
have some friends out here
sometimes i see tim green out here as
well um
but uh yeah it's it's like every month
so i kind of kind of live out here you
know seven year old bedroom that you
used to sleep in
yeah man it hasn't changed since 1989.
i mean there's a couple of new things
but here's some drawings i made
in high school
yep here's that's not mine this is
another one that i made
let's see if you get the glare
it's crazy yeah so my gratitude journal
yeah this morning my gratitude journal
app gave me a quote it said
every child is an artist problem
is staying that way when you grow up
and the quote was pablo picasso
oh [ __ ] yeah i think uh do you think
that you that you've managed to stay an
artist
yeah you know i mean my thing is like
you know growing up i was like well i'm
probably not gonna have kids
um because i feel like such a big kid
and i'm
only child and i feel kind of selfish
you know in that way but uh
but uh so i've always just had like a
you know i
it's like a peter pan complex or
something like that you know like i'm
always going to be a kid you know
whatever i was getting ready to ask for
more accents dude what was that one dude
well i don't know what that one is i
think that's just a general uh
you know there's a guy yeah he's either
a guy
stuff he knows or it's just the way he
grew up speaking you know it's like
swaggy
he's a deviated septum
no but all my favorite artists they're
they're all still kids at heart
you know they i mean you have to have
that otherwise uh
i mean that's the other thing like that
whole idea of like being a you know kid
at heart
it's it's not like an extra thing you
know what i mean it's like
and it's not it's not even like just for
kids it's just like always having
curiosity about the world around you is
that's not really it's just a human
thing
and i think like adults are always like
well
you've got a childlike curiosity it's
like well
i mean everybody should always be
curious most human beings are curious i
mean you look at hidden prank shows and
stuff or people pulling tricks
people turn into kids like
instantaneously you know it's uh
it's not like a it's not like an extra
thing that you had to work at holding on
to or
man you've got me questioning whether
i've ever even been an
artist oh god i'm just an intention
i'm just an attention [ __ ] dude it's
not even about like
i'm certainly not curious it's not like
i don't think
i think what you what you guys did and
what you what you do
what you did especially uh is definitely
art because what it does is it i mean
like for you and simon eddie for
instance
that part what a great partnership
you're coming up with crazy [ __ ]
that you couldn't quite pull off
yourself but you're suggesting and then
he's like oh [ __ ]
yeah you're creating videos you come up
with skate tricks i mean that's all
artists right yeah
like you reject the shackles of
adulthood that like society puts on
other people like you don't
you you duct taped yourself to a bill
it's exciting so that people would look
at me because i'm an attention
you could do this i mean that's
basically it it's like
hey guys you could do this yeah i could
i don't know if i
would but i i'm glad you're doing it
yeah
you have to market the art somehow right
so you're both
you're two departments in yeah well
thank you ma'am thank you
i'm true so how
how does one ask this like uh just pull
the trigger all right
like are are you are you pretty wealthy
you know
was that rude because i just wanted to
know and we are going to find out
but first let me tell you about this
problem that i have
ah i'm going on a road trip in the rv
and i love road trips but i've gotten to
a point where i
can't stand leaving the house because i
know
that means i might have to poop without
my hello tushy bidet
it's attached to every toilet in my
house i
love it it is my favorite product that i
have
ever promoted on the wild ride podcast
and if you haven't tried it yet
you're out of your mind it's so simple
to get it on your toilet
the way that it works after you poop you
just twist the dial
and it'll just blast your butthole and
just
it's like pressure cleaning it gets so
clean it's so
satisfying i genuinely love it
so much and when i'm on the road
closest i can get to that is wet wipes
you gotta try it
so go to hellotushy.com
stevo i'm telling you it is the greatest
hellotissue.com and you get 10
off your order plus free shipping this
is the most important thing you can do
for your butthole i'm telling you it may
be
the most important thing you can do
period so go get yourself a hello tushy
and now let's talk about money
i've never got outside where that's wow
are you pretty well
what's pretty wealthy
here's the thing right as we've
discussed with all kinds of different
personalities on the podcast i really
get the sense
that there are a lot of people uh
just making way
[ __ ] more money than i am and i feel
like i'm working so hard all the time
well now let me ask you this so i'm
trying to just get a sense like
how hard do you feel like
steve are you pretty wealthy i mean i i
think i'm
doing pretty well for myself you know
uh but i think that i think that uh
i do a lot of the same [ __ ] as
some really wealthy people and i'm
nowhere [ __ ] near
them you know we were talking to well
you're not an artist
so i mean it's not about the money but
you know
still like like what do they got i like
to ask people uh your
your bank statements no no your top
three revenue streams i'll be right back
top three revenue streams how about that
we don't need any numbers but
but um revenue streams well i mean i got
the late late show
which is like my my constant paycheck
um and and they pay and they pay pretty
well i mean
you know every year it kind of like goes
up a little bit
um so that's that's good that's like my
baseline and then uh
and then i have like and i kind of like
think of it as
uh anything else on top of that is like
extra
so i think of that as like the spending
money and because i don't have a family
i don't have a kid or anything like that
it's just me so i don't have any
overhead so
uh you know so so that's one that's the
main one then the second one would be
like you know gigs like uh
live stuff like when live stuff used to
happen
and so a tour i'd do live gigs and then
another one would be like like square
box
yeah you know like and those kind of gig
so like you know voice over or
commercial thing like you know firefox
or
keurig or something like that something
that curious
yeah yeah i did a keurig commercial with
the james corden
which is pretty fun but a lot of that
stuff comes out of the blue it's like
it's
even in this time you know where i was
like i'm gonna go see my mom and you
know and i don't i'm not flying
commercial yet
so i have a deal with a charter company
and it's pricey to
to fly private but it's also just safer
um and uh because i go so often and
you know sometimes my money managers are
like dude what are you doing i'm just
like well it's my mom
and uh secondly uh it's my
you know i yeah it's my mom yeah so uh
you know so there's that but then like
weirdly i'll just get a gig out of the
blue they'll be like here's a gig for
a very large chunk of money and that
that requires
you know an hour of your time and i'll
be like this is just crazy it's like the
universe is going like no you need to
see your mom we'll make sure you keep
getting some cash in there so i you know
those are my three
my kind of three revenue streams that i
could think of
yeah and it's it's pretty rad man like
you know some of these people i'm
talking about you know not even like uh
mention anybody but i feel like there's
a level of
of celebrity where like life becomes
kind of just a pain in the ass you know
like people are after you
like you get scandals and views and i
think that
you know i'm getting by and i'm like not
big enough of a deal that anybody really
gives a [ __ ] if i
say something [ __ ] up you know like i
don't have like
paparazzi or any weird [ __ ] like that i
kind of go through life
like without too much hassle but i'm
getting by
you know so i kind of like i kind of
like the level where i'm
at yeah i i hear you 100
and you're in a really good spot because
the thing is you set the bar
like you know of how outrageous and
crazy
you've done like the range is so huge
that
it like whatever you're going to say or
whatever you're going to do
aside from like killing somebody but but
you know what i mean like anything that
you'd say that's kind of outrageous like
people are going to be like oh okay
that's cool so in a way you're very free
because you've you've started free so
you're going to always be free and
that's kind of like
my thing too well i feel like you did
that in the past like you've already had
those ups and downs and now when like
paparazzi sees you or people they're
like stoked to see you they're like dude
steve what's up
like what cool yeah that's the take i
get like
being around you you know it's like
people are stoked i'm sure back in the
day it was kind of more of a [ __ ] show
and like
but i never i didn't give a [ __ ] you
know i think that we've learned
like time and time again that there
actually is
very much such a thing as
bad publicity you know they say all
publicity is good publicity that's not
true
that's not true at all but i've been
fortunate that like for me
like getting arrested has always been
like pretty good for me
it's pretty good man that's good
i mean that's like the thing that most
people would be terrified
of and the fact that you're like i've
been arrested
yeah dude have you ever been arrested
um i was arrested once yeah uh
for i think was that the only time i
think i think
the only time i can remember but uh yeah
for shoplifting oh
nice we're in montanans no in seattle
actually
um i stole some vegan chili
some vegan chili and a an essential
sandwich which is like a
pita wrap thing company uh that makes
sandwiches and uh
yeah i got busted and thrown in the back
of the car and
yeah it was crazy but i worked it off my
record for doing community service at my
local arts college and they just let me
let me off pretty lightly uh 47
no um i was probably
26.
that's a little bit too old to be doing
that or no yeah 26
yeah or actually no i was probably 25
because i just gotten into cornish
college of yards are you are you uh
you still working out a lot i i saw some
[ __ ] on you and like you're pretty
[ __ ] jacked
yeah i have been i haven't i still work
out about
you know three to four times a week with
a with a private one-on-one session with
my trainer
and it's good but kovid
you know i grew up like yo-yoing
weight-wise
um and uh kobet i definitely
lost there's something going on here
where i'm like
i know i shouldn't but yeah it's
postmates time again you know so
i've definitely put on some pounds but
at least i still keep working out so i
feel like
cardiovascularly i'm pretty good and
still have
strength and things like that but i'm
just like not happy about it
get ready with that sample you put on
the covid 19.
yeah and then q steely dan
hey 19.
so you're born you were born in in
germany
i was born in england oh [ __ ] right
so so how many passports do you have
i wish i had more than one man uh i my
parents never got savvy enough to
my mother's french from france and i
don't know why she never
worked to get me a french passport but
uh
because it's the eu basically yeah the
united states of europe so you're good
on europe
but we're were your parents not born
in other countries uh my my mother was
born in france
and uh in northern france and was there
until she
moved away with my dad when she was 30.
my dad's from cleveland ohio well there
you go so you're american
uh yeah i'm american but you know the
funny thing was
you know i was born in stuttgart um
home of porsche um and
uh a sports stuttgart and then uh i we
moved around europe because my dad was
in the air force
and i didn't have citizenship so i
didn't have i was a non-citizen until
age five which i thought was
pretty cool naturalize yeah exactly
yeah where's the u.s passport
what's that that's the one he has you
have one passport which
i only have one i only have one which is
what
u.s oh well that's [ __ ] [ __ ] you
totally are entitled to a german
passport
and a french passport i you know i would
love it i think if i spent time in
germany i could get it
i got three i had three [ __ ]
passports because i was born in england
my mom was born in canada
my dad was born in the states so yeah
you're like
so stoked you can pull out like the
canadian passport when you want people
to just be like uh he's a good guy
yeah english if you're just like like
listen man
um i've got some serious business to do
and then the americans like hey man
i'm american so
[Laughter]
you will let me into this country right
now here's my british i'm sorry
i mean sorry just let me in
yeah what did the canadian sound like oh
you know a boat
you know it's like depends on when
you're wearing your toque or not
you want some loonies
the toonies and the loonies and loonies
man
so when the world is actually uh
spinning and [ __ ] like that and there is
uh you know live touring like what what
does a
reggie watch tour look like you know in
the in the past it hasn't you know
the word tour brings you know so many
images to mine but really
for me it's been like in recent years i
had a tour manager but it was
just me going solo you know everywhere
i'd go i was just
me and my backpack and my roll away that
was it that was
that was my whole touring apparatus then
i started adding a sound
engineer slash tour manager which really
made things
a lot better but i do dream of doing a
tour
like a proper like bus tour uh in the
u.s
uh at some point and uh just make it
like
super like rock and roll you know just
like have like friends join in
join you know they can fly and fly out
whatever different dates and stuff and
and just have a really good time and
invite some amazing artists and just do
you know and spend like a few days in
each city as opposed to just like
hitting city after city because this
would just be for fun
um because i've always wanted to do like
uh we're on the road guys you're like
like
we love you come on look at us [ __ ]
love it have you been to every state in
the united states
you know i was thinking about that the
other day i i think i've been to
i think i have been to every state
except for
no i went to alaska yeah yeah alaska
hawaii i'm trying to think of a state
that i might not you know i may i might
not have
i might have driven through nebraska but
i don't know if i've been to
nebraska i know definitely wyoming north
dakota
south dakota for sure just trying to
think of the weird the weird moment
i'm missing the dakotas dude i'm missing
montana and alaska in maine
those are the ones you haven't been to
yeah yeah montana is the [ __ ] man
i've been to montana yeah i want to do
that i want to see uh what's in south
dakota too the uh where all the
presidents are up on the
mount i saw it it's anticlimactic it's
so small
it's like way smaller than you think
you're 100 right about that i remember
seeing it i was like oh
okay yeah it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
kind of i mean it's just like yeah
it was a letdown kind of for me just
because it was yeah it's so small i was
like oh
all right so we should fly there and get
a private charter just to fly as close
to it i think we can do that we're
trying to work on that from sioux falls
yeah let's see how the charters the
private jets work for
what's up with what's up with the
private jet company dude
man you know i'm actually i feel you
know i don't feel the greatest about
taking private jets is because
environmentally they're kind of a
disaster but i do take
i do take small jets so they're very
small jets and they do
have a smaller footprint more efficient
but i i am i'm like a super futurist
like i want everybody to like
i don't want anybody to change their
lifestyle i just want to like change the
energy source you know i mean it's like
if you want to own like a ridiculous
suv which i [ __ ] can't stand the suvs
but but if
if you wanted to own one of those at
least if it was hydrogen powered or
electric
i'd be you know i'd feel better about it
but there are hydrogen
uh planes coming out to market soon
hydrogen
we just got [ __ ] hella called out for
the rv dude
no but rv is different i got a tesla
dude so i don't have any carbon
footprint
i have my minecart my car's a chevy volt
oh that's great yeah i'm getting a
porsche tycoon so
that's that's an electric car have you
seen those have you seen the tunnels
that virgin
is building the underground
bro unbelievable it's sick right yeah
yeah i mean
yeah theoretical speeds up to 600 700
miles per hour dude like well and then
and then
tesla has one or elon musk has one from
like la to vegas it takes you there like
in 45 minutes so it's like a train
yeah and like you sit down like you
would like how do you explain that like
you're in a um
you know a nice chair lift right there's
like you know yeah
or or like you know when we fi fly
american and we're in first and there's
only like four seats in the front it
kind of looks like that
and then it just goes underground just
right to it yeah it's
it's a magnetically levitated uh
car essentially and then you know the
design it just depends on how big the
tunnel is but
yeah you're in that and then it's a
vacuum you know the drive-through bank
deposit where they [ __ ]
yeah that's like official yeah yeah
that's exactly it it's the same thing
because it's a vacuum
so it's like because it has like there
is no air resistance that's why they can
get those speeds it's
crazy so they can get 607 700 miles per
hour because there's no wind resistance
can you get stuck in there because i
would [ __ ] cry
that would kind of suck i would you know
as long as i had air i'd be okay
i just chill you know but uh but i mean
that's such a i mean that between that
and the
uh you know there's a bunch of uh
supersonic uh
passenger planes that are being
developed right now by boom and a couple
a couple others so we're gonna have
supersonic flight again
um but it's quieter like past 700
no that's like mach 2 2.5 you know right
now passenger planes are you're flying
at about
500 i guess 500 yeah 500 miles per hour
dream of living in the future how fast
is supersonic supersonic's just over
mock
it's yeah mock yeah because it's sound
barrier anything that's
faster which is how many miles per hour
like the [ __ ] russian mig fighter jet
that i was in yeah but huh
that was faster than sound yeah official
miles per hour
so it's a super sonic yeah it's faster
than sound
yeah i don't know what that is no way
supersonic means faster than that hey
siri
how fast is the sound barrier
i wish sonics was that fast
[Laughter]
even faster that's [ __ ] hilarious
dude
yeah well before that i was thinking
because you know being stuck in one of
those [ __ ] things would be miserable
but i i was stuck in an elevator
dangling above the serious building
thanks to steve
like 64 floors up i learned this trick
i learned this trick in college when
when the elevator is closing
right you get your fingers in there
right when it closes in the middle
and then you let it go up and in between
floors you pull it open
and you stop the elevator right in
between floors and you can pee down the
elevator shaft and stuff like that
oh that's how you do that yeah yeah yeah
yeah so we were at the
sirius xm building and uh and and i was
like
there's a bunch of people in the
elevator i was like oh check it out
dudes
and i [ __ ] stopped the elevator but
it wouldn't
[ __ ] go against they had like
was it did fire people come everybody
came dude
like the [ __ ] were trapped they
were just trying to go on their lunch
break they're like
15 minutes and yeah i was such a dick
well we made it right like we found out
who they were we sent them some gift
cards and some lunch or whatever
were people real pisso were they like
yelling at you nobody nobody
said anything to that effect but i mean
come on dude it was like
yeah we were in there with somebody in
there just freaking out like [ __ ] dude i
was kind of like thinking like
bro we're just dangling like 64 stories
up
like it's just my biggest fear dude ever
yeah i really uh
my trick backfired on me well but that's
back to what we were saying like the
the expectation of steve oh yeah you're
an artist that was your art
if like if matt damon did that everyone
might be like wow [ __ ] matt damon but it
was like oh steve would do that like
he would you know oh that's to be
expected yeah exactly that's stevo b and
stevo
yeah just breaking systems have you
have you yet to paint your masterpiece
how do i have yet to paint my match
which i don't know
dude i got some coming up that that i'm
uh
that are pretty masterful little [ __ ]
it can be really bad
what about you reggie you think you've
painted your masterpiece yet
painted my masterpiece no not yet am i
uh
no you have something in mind yeah i
think that there's some
there's some things uh that i think
people are gonna
really dig in the future if i can pull
it together but it's
i think it's gonna happen yeah nice man
it's [ __ ] right on
and uh once again because we have
the watts app it's w-a-t-t-s-a-p-p
yeah whatsapp which is it's a play on
whatsapp
yeah yeah it's sort of a pub yeah it's
encrypted messages
from all over the world yes
yeah i mean it was pretty funny because
i was i was just thinking like what's up
i wasn't really thinking about what's up
i was just thinking like oh what could i
call my app
oh yeah what's up that's so funny so
stupid yeah dude i like it man
how long have you had that uh probably
oh geez maybe like at least like nine
months or something like that okay good
so get it yeah get on there man get on
the watts app
so you're making a [ __ ] load of money on
there or what oh man you have no idea
no i i i'm not it's a it's free
it's a free app there's no registering
yeah i wish i wish no it's it's mostly
the app is just more for for fans i just
want to have fun and i can put
dumb [ __ ] on there and i don't have to
like look at stupid ig all the time
so yeah i just sew over the i mean i'll
keep using it but
uh it's just ig and [ __ ] face [ __ ]
and all those uh companies i mean
they're trying their best
you know i mean you know facebook the
thing i have to remember about companies
that i don't like
because of aesthetic reasons or because
they're just not using their
potential very well uh is that it's a
lot of people so it's just
it's people so i can't really be fully
against it
but uh because i definitely met some
great people from facebook for sure
but you know i just don't like the
people who had it
yeah it's like it's like you know it's
it's like such a bummer to me so for me
i was like well i gotta
if i create an app at least i can
control the aesthetics it won't look
like a piece of [ __ ]
and uh you know and people can go on it
and uh
and know that all it is is what you're
seeing there's no social [ __ ]
plus like you can you can structure it
to really pull
more data from them too oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] you facebook better than you
guys
yeah i didn't want to give away all my
secrets but uh yeah
you should probably pull the plug it's
not working all of a sudden it's blacked
out and you just
hacked into our whole [ __ ] yeah there's
nothing han solo can do
do we have uh other than the the watts
app
uh do we have anything else that we want
to plug and promote or we're selling
merch
through the app like do you have a
website where he's with an online store
um it's the yeah i mean through the app
there's a store you just hit the store
button
and uh you can buy whatever it is on
there and my assistant jamie will send
it to you um
nice that's that's kind of it so far i
don't have any merch yet but i'm working
on it
um it's basically it's kind of like
it's sitting there and it's and there's
like stuff posted on it right now but
it's not like
full force as of yet once i get my
my little interface app finished in the
spring
then i'll um i'll be able to do live
streams like whenever and you'll always
get notification when i'm going live or
whatever so
because you ring that bell like a
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah subscribe
guys if you're interested click click up
here and subscribe
or click
yeah dude well right on brother man it's
been a
a real a real treat dude and and i'd
love to
point everybody to reggie watts on
youtube so you can see this incredible
musical improvisation dude your singing
voice is incredible you're
[ __ ] all the samples putting it all
together is it the one man band it's
like
a really [ __ ] impressive art
that that you perform man oh man
i appreciate that very much i love it
and i'm a big fan of yours as well man
just really groovy just for the right
spirit thanks man
i appreciate that dude you know like i i
don't ever like to bump you i don't ever
try to bum anybody out
you know like i don't want anybody to
expect
to get stuck in an elevator because i'm
in the house
sorry to bring it up it's all good dude
don't even worry about no no no
no that's just important those people
have a great story to tell
someone did i think uh there's a video
on youtube somewhere
of it yeah if i do we put the video on
youtube i'm sure it's in one of our
vlogs
oh [ __ ] traps a bunch of people in
an elevator but
that was your masterpiece dude it was
one of them yes
well right on brother we'll let you get
back to your day and i just want to say
thank you again for uh
just doing this with us man it's really
cool oh man
absolutely and uh thanks for introducing
me to mr brisk
risky business was that not
like the most flowing casual
fun and enjoyable conversation it was
wasn't it
yeah reggie watts man you know what to
do
grab a screenshot and blast it out there
tag them let them know that you enjoyed
it
i'm just a huge fan of his now and you
know what i'm not a fan of is
leaving to go on a road trip knowing
that i can't blast my butthole with
my hello toshi bidet i'm serious about
that
i mean dude but i do love road trips and
i gotta go so thanks for watching